du siehst aus wie jemand der dieses Jahr
Tomaten anbauen möchte egal ob auf dem
Balkon oder im Gemüsegarten jetzt
langsam wird es Zeit für die Aussaat und
wenn die Pflänzchen ungefähr so groß
sind dürfen die dann in eigene Töpfchen
umziehen das ganze nennt sich pikieren
und dabei die Pflanzen einfach
vorsichtig aus der Erde raushebeln dann
an den Blättern anfassen nicht am
Stängel der ist nämlich ultra
empfindlich ihr könnt auch die Wurzeln
dann so ein ganz bisschen einkürzen das
regt noch mal das Wurzelwachstum an war
mir jetzt ja einhändig mit Kamera in der
Hand ein bisschen zu kompliziert dann
kommen die in die Erde und zwar so dass
sie bis zu den untersten Blättern in der
Erde stecken dann bilden die nämlich
noch mehr Wurzeln zum Beschriften nehme
ich immer hier diese Eisstäbchen die
sind nämlich schön billig und wenn man
mit Bleistift drauf schreibt dann ist
das ganze auch wasserfest und es bleiben
ja meistens noch so ein paar schwächere
Pflanzen übrig die man jetzt nicht
umgetopft hat die lasse ich noch mal ein
bisschen Leben als Backup falls meinen
guten Pflanzen was passiert und
natürlich das Angießen nicht vergessen